the best in the business is mmqb the the
mmqb is a must read every single monday
uh here on a friday before the bulk of
pre-season week number two 2021 is none
other than albert breer how are you
albert
i'm good i'm good it was good to get a
refresher on the uh lyrics to the
victors there since uh you don't hear
that song very much when they play us so
uh good to hear that you know albert
it's all good in the hood man
it's all good uh let me just jump in
with that one real quick because i had
herb street on earlier this week and my
suggestion that um
you know i i know that the big ten and
the acc
and the um pac-12 are all
reportedly talking and very close to
announcing their own
formation of some sort of relationship
um is coming but is there a possibility
that ohio state my eyes are peeled on
ohio state and clemson because if they
peel off
um to join the sec that would be
maybe the final blow to anybody who
thinks traditionally that this
construct of college football is going
to stay put albert yeah what are you
hearing i i'll be i'll be honest with
you rich i mean you know that might be
good for you know my school's football
program but i i'd hate to see that i
mean i
i think one of the the the beautiful
things about college football is how
um the history goes back i mean it's
over in a lot of cases the history these
rivalries older than the nfl you know
what i mean like it's older than pro
football
and um you know like so i think you know
the nature of the sport you know outside
of maybe notre dame is pretty regional
and you know a lot of this stuff goes
back to you know our grandfathers and
our great grandfathers and so um you
know i i can understand what they're
trying to do here and i think that there
was i and and look i get on cover
college football today and herbie be
much better to answer this than me but
um you know it feels like we've been
going and we've been kind of like
building towards there being whatever it
is like 55 or 60 schools
that you know could have the power to
separate from the ncaa kind of be their
own thing um i'd hate to see that be 20
schools you know what i mean like i i
just i i
think like having
at least a possibility you know that out
there that like a
you know like an oregon becomes what
oregon's become a wisconsin has become
whatever wisconsin's become like i love
that stuff you know what i mean like so
i mean even like lsu like i remember
when i was a kid they weren't that good
you know what i mean that nick saban got
there now they're like a you know
powerhouse you know it's just part of
the beauty of college football is like
the regional nature of it and
you know the fact that sometimes we get
these teams these schools that
traditionally aren't great they can come
up and become those sorts of those pro
those sorts of programs and so it really
sucked to lose that i i think you'd
probably agree with me on no doubt of
course there's no question about it but
that's the way it's going and i'm
wondering have you spoken to anybody in
the league about um what what a
potential super league at the collegiate
level where money is now being pumped in
name image and likeness uh to certain
players to the tune of seven figures and
how that will all work we're making
people eligible for the next level and
because i know i know agents have
already been given the green light
by the uh players association to start
doing name image and likeness deals on
behalf of the collegiate players right
now right which yeah which is crazy like
the rule actually like the rule actually
reads now that they can enter into
marketing agreements with the players
now they can't like sign deals that says
you're gonna be like like representation
for contracts in the nfl but i mean we
all know what that is right like i mean
if you're
signing with a guy to to be your
marketing agent on niall stuff like well
that agent's getting involved there
because he thinks he's going to be your
nfl agent too
um so you know i think that breaks down
some of the walls that that you know i i
think we're probably in some cases
imaginary to begin with you know like i
think we all know like what happens with
ages and college players anyway so maybe
it formalizes that a little bit
i do think that there's actually a
benefit for the nfl here though
in that
you know in a lot of cases guys feel
pressure to go pro as early as they can
and a lot of times it's because a guy
has to i mean support his family like a
guy a guy's entire family might be
counting on him to change the dynamic
you know in their lives and
it you know i wonder this like kind of
come up what has come up repeatedly you
know when i've talked to to guys who you
know
scout that level of football is the hope
here is that maybe what we'll see now
is with these guys having an ability to
make money at the college level the
junior who probably needs another year
but might feel pressured to go and then
winds up getting drafted in the seventh
round maybe that guy stays in school an
extra year and that's good for the
player that's good for the nfl teams
that's good for everybody okay you know
and so i i think that there are some
like you said there are some i think
there's some thorniness the whole thing
of course because anytime you put your
pump money into anything that's you know
there's going to be that sort of stuff
but i do think there's a real benefit
here and that it might wind up
you know getting kids from tough
backgrounds
money earlier and then maybe more of
those kids you know wind up being able
to make more coherent decisions about
whether or not to go in the nfl and
maybe a few more of those kids walk away
with college degrees as a result of it
even if the nfl doesn't work out so i do
think that there's like a real benefit
to all of this and that you know the
guys the kids who are under a lot of
pressure to make money because they come
from tough backgrounds now being able to
do that at the college level i think
takes a little pressure off of those
kids as far as making decisions on when
to go to the nfl interesting so the
whole world isn't going to complete crap
well done albert got some nice that's
some nice uh
positivity right there albert breer
going uh um
right here right here on the rich eisen
show so uh your tours of training camp
or who you were able to visit um give me
some under the radar something we're not
talking about some story that you saw
some person uh coach or player uh that
you think is on the launching pad for
success what do you have for me
on that front
um under the radar well so i mean like i
i mean like one thing that i thought was
interesting and it's just like top of
mind for me because
um you know i i was just with the bucks
and
you know i i think like a lot of people
have sort of like got brady's influence
wrong and it's changed a lot of things
in the nfl like we see how russell
wilson's conducted himself and how aaron
rodgers conducted himself over the last
six months and i think a lot of that is
this perception
that brady's running the bucks
and that's not what's happening um
they're calling brady when they make
moves brady will tell them when he you
know thinks something's the right move
but he's not trying to run the
organization it's so interesting talking
to those guys about it rich because they
actually say like the biggest impact
he's having on their roster construction
is actually in the player development
end and so and this is a great example i
thought um you know one of the guys said
to me that donovan smith who's been
there starting left tackle for a few for
i think five six years now who's a
really good player
um you know him being around brady like
has taken him from being like you know
whatever like maybe like the 11th to
15th best of tackle in football
to now being able to kind of find a
different level and maybe he becomes one
of the elite and the reason why
is because he gets to be around brady
and he sees how brady works this isn't a
young guy this is a guy who's an
established veteran player
they see like their veteran players
trying to reach another level because
they see
how brady is kind of always finding
something different to make him better
so that was really interesting um
just as far as under the radar i mean
the league's so well covered now you
don't need me to tell you that right um
you know i i think
i think one of the things that
i to me
i i i would say
like i i would say like
that that's sort of like a league-wise
thing is
as a result of the off-season programs
being curtailed the way that they were
i there have been more injuries across
the nfl soft tissue stuff than before
and coaches are not happy about it and
as a result of that what you're seeing
is teams are doing more
to
change what they do from a strength and
conditioning standpoint and i'll give
you an example of two opposite ends of
the spectrum yep so brandon staley out
in jacks
out in la out there with the chargers
um when i was there was running an hour
and a half practice right everything was
very efficient and and they got off the
field really quickly the first i think
it was 20 minutes that practice they
were doing yoga on the field and they
were doing all these different things
that were you wouldn't expect to see a
football practice
right and it was
i think you know really kind of forward
thinking and brandon explained it to me
and all the different things that he's
done to kind of
um you know i i think build that program
and and and have it be what he wants
um then you know i i go to jacksonville
and
give me some way urban's doing it and
it's a little more old school but
there's still an efficiency to it their
practices are are are longer it's harder
um and these are two guys like opposite
ends of the country trying to establish
their programs and doing what they think
is best and doing it different ways
and so you know i think that's going to
be kind of like an underlying thing to
the nfl season where because what
happened off season programs because
most coaches believe these guys didn't
get enough work
in the spring didn't get enough football
specific work in the spring there have
been a lot of issues with injuries with
soft tissue injuries this summer and to
combat it like i think there are like a
few coaches across the nfl that are
doing things in a wildly different way
and it'll be really interesting to see
what happens when we get to the seas and
what state teams stay healthy and which
teams don't so we'll see if uh if the
chargers wind up having like an air juan
relationship here uh in los angeles yeah
well it's funny too how it kind of like
matches up right like the team is doing
yoga is out in l.a
you know running boot camps in
florida there you have it it's
very on brand for the for for
albert here on the rich eisen show okay
week one starters quarterbacks give me
give them to me best you can tell right
now right on the cusp of preseason week
number two give me give it to me what do
you got for me alberto first rounders
yes sir well let's take the two off the
table we know that first right
yeah jacksonville and i think one nuance
that a lot of people have missed to the
group of five right
quarterbacks here
is normally
first-round quarterbacks go to bad teams
for obvious reasons because good teams
generally have established quarterbacks
good teams are picking lower generally
first round quarterbacks go to bad teams
that's not the case this year i mean you
get the two um in in trevor lawrence and
zach wilson they're going to rebuilding
teams of first-year coaches but the
other three
are going to are on teams that have been
in the playoffs really recently and two
of those teams have been in the super
bowl recently so you know i think the
the the difference between zach wilson
and trevor lawrence
and and then justin feels trey lance and
um and mac jones is the teams they went
to
i think in all three of those cases
the veterans gonna start the season so
my guess would be cam newton starts week
one
in new england jimmy garoppolo starts
week one in san francisco andy dalton
starts week one in chicago
i think trey lance is going to play the
earliest of the three because i think
kyle shanahan is going to incorporate
him in the offense from the jump so i
think you're going to see treylands on
the field
in week one how mike what do you think
my guess for huh how like what like next
to like there'll be a package where
garoppolo comes off and lances there or
or lance is literally standing to the
right of garoppolo they're gonna now i
think they're gonna they're going to
they're gonna find ways to get him on
the field a quarterback okay and i think
it's
i think it might look a little bit like
taysom hill um in new orleans but i
think it's smart by kyle too like i
think he
my sense of it is like he feels like
jimmy's the best starter for them right
now but he also knows that that could
change over the course the next three or
four months so in addition to giving
other teams something to prepare for
i think he's also thinking well if i get
him in the game
and if i you know if there's somewhere
in my head i'm thinking like maybe about
the time by the time we get to the end
of the year we want trey lance out there
as a starter well it makes sense to get
him into the games in some capacity now
so he's at least
acclimated to game speed right like a
real nfl game speed
so like i think we'll see trey lance
first of those three on the field
i i think that mac jones and um
and and justin fields will start at some
point this year if you put a gun to my
head right now
um i'd say mac jones is starting
sometime in october
and i like justin fields i think it's
like completely contingent
on where the bears are as a team you
know i think with san francisco and new
england because those guys have a little
bit more job security
like you may see where
i like you know kyle shanahan or bill
belichick makes a move
where the team's winning and they still
say the best thing to do is go to the
rookie i could see that happening i
think with justin fields in chicago a
lot of it's going to be contingent on
things that are out of justin fields
control which is is the team winning in
his andy dalton playing well so i know
that's kind of a cop out but
i think i think what i think we'll see
trey lands on the field first
i i think if you again if you put a gun
to my head i'd say
like mac jones will be on the field
somewhere in october which would i i
think probably make him the first of the
three to actually start again and that's
of course that's a course barring injury
and all of that because that obviously
would change stuff no albert i i would
never force that situation plus i i like
to keep my guests safe like if i could i
put a plexiglas walls around you right
now
so no but let me let me let me just say
this though this whole thing is just an
educated guess anyway like last year
fred said when's justin herbert going to
start your answer would not have been
week two when uh when tarad taylor gets
an uh
an unfortunate jab from from a team
doctor you know what i mean like you
would never
say anything like that this is all an
educated guess i just you know fields
and uh uh
he he threw the whole damn route tree on
clemson you know and i know that
clemson's a different story than the
national football league but my gosh i
mean uh you there's so many factors
that's out of obviously fields control
but some of them are also in his favor
the fans you know i mean fans are going
to be
pounding the table i mean i know i i
don't know if
if nagi's gonna have the the the um
uh room physically yeah figuratively to
to to do what he wants to do which he's
told me on this show he wants to do
which is to have
the uh uh dalton be the role of alex
smith and fields the role of mahomes
that he had
so
they love justin they think justin's the
best and why not i i i had somebody i
had somebody there say like i somebody
there say to me
like this organization has never had a
quarterback like this which is a pretty
strong statement even though the bears
have had their issues in the position
right
so like i i do think that like i i i do
think that there's like a desire to like
see what he looked like in a real nfl
game here's the way that the the coaches
see it and i i want to take you inside
like the way that this whole thing i
think is what it's going to boil down to
fantastic so just say matt maggie gives
you a 12 word play call right
the difference between the two in camp
has been and this isn't justin's fault
but the difference between the two in
camp has been when andy dalton enters
the huddle
as he's spitting out the play call he is
talking to each of his teammates so he
is
there's one part of the play call he's
talking to the receiver there's another
part of the play call he's talking to
the left guard there's another part of
the play call he's talking to the
running back so the play call goes in
his ear and he basically is directing
the offense on where to go when justin
fields gets in the huddle
he's getting the play call and he's just
trying to spit it out because he's
memorized it you know what i mean like
and so i think that's the best way to
illustrate the difference between the
two
and where
like
matt maggie and john d filippo and bill
laser and all the guys there feel like
justin's got to get he's got to get to
the point where he can command the
huddle in that way and that's harder for
quarterbacks now because as you know
rich in college they're not doing that
right like it's not even about just
going into the office for not only how
to do a period because in college
they're getting the call from the side
everyone's getting the call from the
sidelines and i know what you and i
think what you're saying albert and you
know is is a terrific insider point
that's why you are an excellent insider
that's an excellent inside point
and that the bears as long as they can
uh keep the kid who's memorizing stuff
wrote off the field so the veteran who
can actually
um take the play absorb it talk to
everyone as the coaching staff wants to
to have the control necessary that's
obviously the best way to run an offense
in the nfl but let's not forget
sometimes circumstances rise up and you
got to stick the kid out there because
again what happened for herbert or dak
prescott don't forget right when dak was
lighting up the league
you all you were hearing was he can only
check out one half of the field at a
time because the way that he can't
synthesize everything so fast because it
is still a faster game so what dak
prescott
retired tony romo you know what i mean
so so
so that's what bears fans are probably
sitting there thinking like screw it i'd
rather get the dak prescott stuff now
than have to you know put my hands and
i'd rather have my hands on you know
white knuckling in the the wheel then
say okay we're going to do the sensible
thing right i mean that's that that's
exactly why that that's exactly why
though like if you've heard matt talk
about it over the last few weeks like
what he's what he keeps saying
is we need to see justin that's why
they've planned since may to have him in
the games a lot like
like why he played i mean i don't know
how many snaps he played last week but
it was a lot you know and and and they
plan on playing them a lot this week and
next week because they want to see what
that looks like when
he's still like again like totally
understandable there's a learning curve
there so they want to see what it looks
like when he's out there
you know dealing with like some of the
the the bumps that learning is going to
present and you can't really learn that
stuff in practice because it's so
controlled right so you put him out
there in a game setting and now you're
getting to see what happens when he's
out there and you do have to maybe like
help him out a little bit in a way you
wouldn't have to help out an 11 year old
an 11 year veteran like like andy dalton
again and maybe they come to the
conclusion i can't say they won't
that
even with like some of these guard rails
we got to put up even with like you know
the training wheels that we got to put
on like we're still better with him in
there it's possible that they come to
that conclusion i think that another key
difference here and that this comes back
to this comes right back to
like who the team is right like so the
jets and the jaguars can afford to ride
out bumps with trevor lawrence and zach
wilson right like they could just be i
mean they can afford to ride that out
they go on a three or four game losing
streak nothing anybody wants that to
happen but you can deal with it
if like you have to go through one of
those periods with justin fields or mac
jones or trey lance for that matter
like i mean you've got a locker room
full of veterans they don't care what's
best for the franchise three years from
now they want to win right now right and
so that's the part of it that i think is
really important with these with you
know like in the locker rooms like the
niners and patriots and bears locker
rooms where it's you don't just have to
sell it to the coaches you don't sell
the fans you gotta sell to the guys in
the locker room and it's a these locker
rooms are full of guys those three teams
are full of guys who've won recently who
have a lot on the line this year who
don't give a crap what's good for the
franchise long term you know what i mean
like they they only care about right now
and so i think that's why how good the
team is and the fact that three of the
five went to teams that really fashion
themselves contenders is a very very
relevant thing albert you're the best
let's chat before the season we'll chat
soon you got it thanks for the rest
that's all always gonna be on love it
love it love it love it great inside
stuff also another reason why coaches
will never give up preseason games you
just heard it
you just heard it why justin fields is
going to get these reps in these
preseason games exactly why coaches will
go down fighting if anybody's like yeah
we'll just do
practices amongst the teams hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here